J’ai jamais fait ça.
Et, tu me trouves comment,
par rapport aux photos?
Ben, disons que
tu maitrises bien Photoshop.
(Rires)
Je me rappelle que
t’avais mis
«sens de l’humour»
dans la description.
Mais là c’en est pas.
Bonsoir!
-Bonsoir jeune homme.
Bonsoir.
Alors ce soir nous vous proposons
un risotto aux morilles
et un colin frit agrémenté
de sa délicieuse huile de truffe.
Du rayon Croustibat en fait.
-Ah, c’est très drôle,
c’est une blague?
ben je vais vous prendre
des petits bouts de vache cuits
agrémentés de ses fines lamelles
de pomme de terre
sur son huile de palme.
Connard.
-Pardon?
Ah ok, j’ai compris.
De toute façon je me casse.
Soirée de merde
dans un resto de merde, avec …
Oh, merci beaucoup, Monsieur, voilà!
Je vous souhaite une très bonne soirée.
Je peux vous offrir un verre?
Tu sais,
j’ai pas l’habitude de faire ça.
Mais j’ai passé un très bon moment.
Aaaaah!
Je t’ai pas dit que ça allait marcher?
T’es un génie mon pote.
-Demain, c’est moi qui fait le serveur.
Alors, t’as bien kiffé?
-Ca s’est super bien passé.
Sérieux?
Il a rien vu.
Demain, c’est moi
qui prends le costume.
Il reste deux capotes dans la poche.